- 양자 정보와 계산의 이해에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요.
저는 John Watrous이고 IBM Quantum의
교육 기술 디렉터예요.
이번은 시리즈의 일곱 번째 레슨이고, 이번 레슨에서는 위상 추정 문제와 양자 컴퓨터로 이걸 어떻게 풀 수 있는지 얘기할 거예요.
그런 다음 위상 추정을 이전 레슨에서 다뤘던 정수 인수분해 문제에 적용할 거예요.
우리가 얻게 될 건 Shor의 알고리즘인데, 이건 정수를 다항 시간 비용으로, 또는 다항 시간 안에 인수분해할 수 있게 해줘요.
필요한 시간이나 기본 연산의 수로
생각하든 상관없이요.
이건 어떤 의미에서
양자 알고리즘의 왕관의 보석 같은 거고, 큰 정수를 인수분해하는 건
대부분의 사람들에게 제한적인 유용성을 가질 수 있지만, 양자 컴퓨터가 놀라운 이점을 제공할 거라는 가설에 대한 가장 설득력 있는 증거 중 하나로 남아 있어요.
고전 컴퓨터에 비해서요. 레슨의 개요는 이래요.
위상 추정 문제 자체의 정의부터 시작하고, 그다음에 양자 컴퓨터로 이 문제를 푸는 방법을 얘기할 거예요.
한 단계씩 진행할 건데, 일종의
워밍업이라고 생각하면 돼요.
위상 추정 문제에서 목표는 특정 실수를 근사하는 건데, 이 워밍업 부분에서는 이 숫자에 대한
아주 낮은 정밀도의
근사를 어떻게 얻을 수 있는지 볼 거예요.
이건 인수분해에 충분하지 않을 거예요. 위상 추정 문제의 풀이를 정수 인수분해에 적용할 때는
실제로 꽤 높은 정밀도의 근사가 필요하지만, 그래도 이런 종류의 워밍업으로 시작하는 게 유용해요.
전체가 어떻게 작동하는지
감을 잡기 위해서요.
그다음에 더 많은 정밀도를 어떻게 얻을 수 있는지 얘기할 건데, 이건 양자 Fourier 변환이라는 연산으로 아주 자연스럽게 이어져요.
이 연산이 정확히 뭔지, 그리고 양자 circuit으로 어떻게 구현할 수 있는지 볼 거예요.
그걸 갖추면, 위상 추정에 적용해서 아주 높은 정밀도로 문제를 푸는 일반적인 절차를 만들 수 있어요.
그리고 레슨의 마지막 부분에서는 위상 추정 문제의 풀이가 어떻게 정수를 효율적으로 인수분해하게 해주는지 볼 거예요.
구체적으로 우리가 얻게 될 건 정수 인수분해를 위한 Shor의 알고리즘이에요. 적어도 Shor의 알고리즘과 동등한 거요.
이게 작동하는 방식은 기본적으로 디딤돌을 놓는 건데, 그건 순서 찾기 문제라는 또 다른 문제예요.
특히 위상 추정 절차를 사용해서 순서 찾기 문제를 어떻게 풀 수 있는지 보고, 그다음에 정수를 어떻게 인수분해할 수 있는지 볼 거예요.
순서 찾기 문제를 풀어서요. 스펙트럼 정리라는 정리의 특수한 경우부터 시작할 건데,
구체적으로 이 정리가 유니터리 행렬에 대해 뭘 말해주는지에 초점을 맞출 거예요.
스펙트럼 정리는 선형대수와
함수해석학에서 아주 중요한 정리예요.
특정 선형 사상이 어떤 형태로 표현될 수 있는지에 대한 흥미로운 걸 알려주는데, 이걸 종종 스펙트럼 분해라고 불러요.
여러 가지 이유로 유용해요.
그리고 말했듯이, 이 정리가 유니터리 행렬에 대해 뭘 말해주는지에 초점을 맞출 거예요.
스펙트럼 정리는 이것보다 더 일반적이에요. 모든 행렬에 대해 작동하진 않지만,
정규 행렬이라 불리는 행렬의 부류에 대해서는 작동하는데, 여기에는 모든 유니터리 행렬과 유니터리가 아닌 일부 행렬도 포함돼요.
하지만 간단하게 유지하기 위해, 지금은 유니터리 행렬에만 주목할 거예요. 이번 레슨의 목적에는 그것만 필요하니까요.
유니터리 행렬에 대한 스펙트럼 정리의 진술은 이래요.
U가 N x N 유니터리
행렬이라고 가정해 봐요.
이 정리가 말하는 건 벡터 psi 1부터 psi N까지의 정규직교 기저가 반드시 존재해야 한다는 거예요.
N개의 복소수 Lambda 1부터 Lambda N까지와 함께, 모두 복소 단위원 위에 있어서 U를 이 방정식처럼 표현할 수 있어요.
이걸 U의 스펙트럼 분해라고 부르는데, 이미 언급했듯이 U를 이런 식으로 쓸 수 있다는 걸 아는 건 아주 편리할 수 있어요.
특정 유니터리 행렬 U를 다룰 때 이 벡터들과 숫자들을 갖고 있으면 편리할 수 있고, 또한 그런 표현이 항상 가능하다는 걸 단순히 아는 것만으로도
유니터리 행렬에 대한 특정한 것들을 증명하는 방법으로 아주 유용할 수 있어요.
이 정리의 진술에서 각 숫자 Lambda 1부터 Lambda N까지는 특정한 방식으로 쓰여 있어요.
E의 2 pi I 곱하기 theta 거듭제곱으로, 여기서 각 theta인 theta 1부터 theta N까지는 실수이고, 이렇게 각 숫자를 쓰는 방식에 대해
조금 뒤에 다시 돌아올 거예요.
이 벡터들과 숫자들에 대해 주목할 중요한 점은 각 벡터 psi K가 행렬 U의 고유벡터여야 하고 대응하는 고유값이 lambda K라는 거예요.
이건 psi K에 U를 곱하면 lambda K 곱하기 psi K를 얻는다는 의미예요.
그래서 U가 이 벡터들 각각에 하는 건 단순히 대응하는 숫자 lambda K를 곱하는 거예요.
일반적으로 임의의 벡터에 대해서는 U가 이렇게 작동하지 않지만, 고유벡터는 특별해요.
그리고 이 정리가 말해주는 건 사실 이 고유벡터들의 정규직교 기저가 존재한다는 거예요.
아래쪽의 이 방정식은, 참고로, 정리에서 U에 대해 가진 표현과 벡터들이 정규직교라는 사실로부터 나와요.
U의 표현을 아무 psi K에 곱하고 벡터들의 정규직교성을 사용하면, 모든 항이 0인 합을 얻게 되는데
하나만 빼고요, 그리고 남는
하나의 항은 이렇게 생겼어요.
이제 위상 추정 문제를
정의할 수 있어요.
이 문제는 우리가 보게 될 것처럼
좀 특이해요.
두 가지가 주어져요. 먼저, 유니터리 양자 circuit의 설명이 주어져요.
어떤 N에 대해 N개의 qubit에
작용하는 거고, 이게 유니터리 circuit이라는 건
모든 gate가 유니터리라는 뜻이에요.
그래서 이 circuit에 측정이 없어요.
둘째로, N qubit 상태 psi가 주어지는데, 이게 특이한 부분이에요.
이 문제에는 실제로 양자 상태
입력이 있고, 이 상태의 단일 복사본이에요.
이 시리즈에서 얘기한 다른 모든 계산 문제에서 입력은 고전적이었어요. 비트 문자열 형태이거나 블랙박스로요.
그리고 그건 놀라운 일이 아닌 게, 일상에서 마주치는 계산 문제들은 고전적인 경향이 있거든요.
왜냐하면 우리가 가장
신경 쓰는 문제들이니까요.
이 문제에 대해 생각할 수 있는 방식은 이게 하위 문제로 나타나거나 나타날 가능성이 있는 거라는 거예요.
그리고 우리가 결국 만들어낼 위상 추정 절차는 일반적으로 서브루틴으로 사용하는 거예요.
더 큰 계산 안에서, 아마도 우리가 관심 있는 고전적 문제를 위한 거요.
자, 이건 약속 문제가 될 거고 상태 psi는 아무 양자 상태가 아니에요.
psi가 주어진 circuit이 설명하는 어떤 유니터리 연산 U의 고유벡터라는 게 약속돼 있어요.
그리고 목표는 고유벡터 psi에
대응하는 고유값을 찾거나 근사하는 거예요.
문제를 좀 더 정확하게
진술해 봐요.
입력은 N qubit에 대한 유니터리 양자 circuit으로, 비트 문자열로 인코딩할 수 있어요.
양자 circuit 설명을 인코딩하기 위한 어떤 방법이든 선호하는 걸 사용해서, N qubit 상태 psi와 함께요.
circuit을 뭐라고 부르든 상관없지만, 이 문제의 진술에서 정말 중요한 건 유니터리 연산 자체예요.
circuit이 실행될 때 수행되는 거고, 그 유니터리 연산은 행렬 U로 설명돼요.
하지만 U가 행렬로 주어지는 게 아니라, U를 구현하는 양자 circuit의 설명만 주어져요.
이미 말했듯이, 약속은 psi가 U의 고유벡터라는 거예요.
그래서 circuit을 psi에 대해 실행하면, 고유값이 뭐든 그걸 곱한 psi가 나오게 되는데,
그 상황에서는 글로벌
위상이 될 거예요.
그리고 마지막으로, 문제의 출력은 psi에 대응하는 고유값의 근사이고, 구체적으로는
0과 1 사이의 실수 theta의 근사를 찾는 거예요. 0은 포함하지만 1은 포함하지 않고,
화면에 있는 방정식을
만족하는 거예요.
psi에 대응하는 고유값을 이렇게 매개변수화하는 방식을 설명하고, 근사가 뭘 의미하는지 명확히 하기 위해
복소 단위원의 그림을
그려 봐요.
숫자 1, i, -1, 그리고 -i를 평소 위치에 놓을 수 있고,
문제 진술에서처럼 theta로 매개변수화된 원 위의 임의의 점을 생각할 수 있어요.
이건 1에서 시작해서 2 곱하기 pi 곱하기 theta만큼의 각도로 회전하면 얻는 점이에요. 그래서 각도는 theta가 아니라 2 pi theta이고,
다른 방식으로 생각하면, 1에서 시작해서 원 자체를 따라 2 pi theta만큼 이동하면
E의 2 곱하기 pi 곱하기
theta 거듭제곱인 점에 도달해요.
복소 단위원의 모든 점은 theta의 유일한 선택에 대해 이런 식으로 표현할 수 있어요.
그건 theta가 0에서 1로 갈 때 원을 한 바퀴 돌기 때문이고, theta가 1까지 가면
theta가 0인 곳으로 다시 돌아오니까, 그래서 0은 포함하지만 1은 포함하지 않는 거예요.
복소 단위원의 각 점이 우리가 고려하는 범위에서 theta의 유일한 값에 대응하게 하기 위해서요.
특정 theta 값을 근사하는 다양한 방법을 상상할 수 있지만, 우리가 할 방식은 theta를 분수로 근사하는 거예요.
분모가 양의 정수 M에 대해 2의 M 거듭제곱이고, 분자는 정수 y인데
0과 2의 M 거듭제곱 빼기 1 사이예요.
이걸 원한다면 theta의 m비트 근사라고 생각할 수 있고, 이 숫자를 이진 표기법으로 쓸 수 있어요.
이진 소수점 뒤에 Y의
이진 표현이 오는 거예요.
참고로 소수점 대신 이진 소수점이라고 하는 건 decimal은 10진법을 뜻하고 여기서는 2진법을 얘기하는 거니까요. 하지만 같은 개념이에요.
어쨌든 화면에 나타난 것처럼
분수로도 생각할 수 있어요.
그리고 명확히 하자면, 이 맥락에서 근사를 생각할 때 theta의 값이
0에 가까운 값과 1에 가까운 값이 실제로는 서로 가깝다는 걸 이해해야 해요.
예를 들어, theta가 0.99이고 이 theta 값을 0으로 근사하면,
그건 실제 값에서 100분의 1 이내라는 점에서 꽤 좋은 근사예요. 원을 따라 돌아서
1에 도달하면 0으로 돌아가니까요.
모듈러 1이라는 용어가 이 상황을 설명하는 데 사용되기도 하는데, 본질적으로 theta가 1인 것과 theta가 0인 것을 같다고 보는 거예요.
핵심은 우리가 정말 신경 쓰는 건 단위원 위의 점 E의 2 pi I theta 거듭제곱의 위치라는 거예요.
이런 방식으로 theta를 근사하는 건 그 목표를 염두에 둘 때 말이 돼요.
화면에 나타난 문제 진술 자체는 theta의 근사가 얼마나 좋아야 하는지 구체적으로 명시하지 않지만,
필요에 따라 세밀하게 조정할 수 있는 거예요.
어떤 상황에서는 theta의 낮은 정밀도 근사로 만족할 수 있고, 다른 상황에서는
아주 높은 정밀도의 근사를 요구할 수 있고, 문제 진술 자체를 그에 맞게 정제할 수 있어요.
다음으로 양자 컴퓨터로 위상 추정 문제를 어떻게 풀 수 있는지 보고, 워밍업부터 시작할 거예요.
이건 문제에 대한 최종
해결책은 아닐 거예요.
우리가 할 건 위상 킥백 현상을 활용해서 주어진 고유벡터에 대응하는 고유값에 대해 뭔가를 배우려는 거예요.
위상 추정 문제에서 우리에게 어떤 연산 U에 대한 유니터리 양자 circuit의 설명이 주어진다는 걸 떠올려 봐요.
그리고 우리가 먼저 하는 건 이 circuit 설명을 사용해서 화면에 그려진 것처럼 제어된 U 연산을 구현하는 새로운 circuit을 만드는 거예요.
이건 꽤 간단해요. 할 수 있는 건 제어 qubit을 추가하는 건데, 이 다이어그램에서 위쪽에 그려져 있고
이 새로운 제어 qubit을 circuit에 나타나는 모든 gate의 제어로 사용하는 거예요.
그래서 이 제어 qubit이 1로 설정되면 모든 gate가 적용되고, 제어 qubit이 0으로 설정되면 아무것도 적용되지 않아요.
그건 circuit U에 나타나는 모든 gate의 제어된 버전이 필요하다는 뜻이지만, 원하지 않으면 이 새로운 제어된 gate들을
단일 gate로 생각할 필요가 없어요. 어떤 gate 집합을 선택했든 그 gate들로 만든 작은 circuit으로 구현할 수 있어요.
그리고 U의 제어된 버전을 갖추면, 이 circuit을 실행하는 걸 생각할 수 있어요.
먼저 제어 qubit을 0과 1의 중첩 상태로 놓고, 주어진 고유벡터 psi에 제어된 U gate를 적용하고,
그런 다음 제어에 Hadamard gate를
적용하고 측정해요.
분석을 진행하면서 왜 이렇게 하는 게 합리적인지 보겠지만, 세부사항에 들어가기 전에도 바로 유사성을 볼 수 있어요.
예를 들어 Deutsch의 알고리즘과의 유사성이요. 거기서도 Hadamard gate 몇 개를 적용하고 측정하는 방식으로 효과적으로 탐색하는 거잖아요.
주어진 연산이 여기서
뭘 하고 있는지를요.
여기서는 쿼리 gate가 아니라 제어된 유니터리지만, 아주 비슷한 아이디어가 작용하고 있어요.
그럼 이 circuit이 뭘 하는지 봐요.
초기 상태는 고유벡터 psi와 제어 qubit의 0 상태를 텐서곱한 거예요.
첫 번째 Hadamard gate를 적용하면 위쪽 qubit의 상태가 플러스 상태로 변환되고, 전체 상태를 여기 보이는 것처럼 전개할 수 있어요.
그런 다음 제어된 U 연산을 적용하는데, 이건 제어 qubit이 1로 설정됐을 때 psi에 U를 적용하지만
0으로 설정됐을 때는 적용하지 않아요. 그래서 화면에 쓰인 상태 pi 2를 얻어요.
psi가 고유값 e의 2 pi I theta 거듭제곱을 가진 U의 고유벡터라는 사실을 이용해서 상태를 단순화할 수 있어요.
그래서 두 번째 항에는 그 고유값이 곱해지지만 첫 번째 항에는 안 곱해져요.
그리고 텐서곱의 쌍선형성을
이용해서 단순화할 수 있어요.
그래서 여기서 보이는 건 위상 킥백 현상인데, 이번에는 어떤 임의의 유니터리 연산 U의 임의의 고유벡터 psi에 대해 일어나고 있어요.
더 구체적으로 말하면 마이너스 상태에 NOT 연산을 적용하는 것과 대비되는 거예요.
그래서 제어된 U 연산이 적용된 후의 상태가 그거예요.
참고로, 아래쪽 N qubit의 상태가 여전히 고유벡터 psi라는 걸 잠깐 주목할 가치가 있어요.
그건 좋은 거예요. 왜냐하면 원한다면
다시 사용할 기회를 주니까요.
그런 다음 두 번째 Hadamard gate가 수행되고 여기 우리가 얻는 상태가 있어요.
유도의 모든 세부사항을 보여주진 않았지만, Hadamard gate를 적용하고 단순화하면 이걸 얻어야 해요.
그래서 그게 측정 직전의
상태예요.
그래서 이 상태에 집중해서 측정으로 theta에 대해 뭘 배울 수 있는지 볼 수 있어요.
그리고 위쪽 qubit이나 가장 오른쪽 qubit을 측정하면, 두 결과에 대해 이런 확률을 얻어요.
여기서 사인과 코사인을 복소 지수함수와 연결하는 몇 가지 기본 공식을 사용해서 이 확률들을
사인과 코사인으로 표현했어요.
구체적으로, 0을 얻을 확률은 pi 곱하기 theta의 코사인 제곱이고, 1을 얻을 확률은
같은 각도의 사인 제곱이에요. 그리고 이건 말이 되는 게, 어떤 각도든 사인 제곱 더하기 코사인 제곱은 1이니까요.
그래서 확률의 합이
예상대로 1이에요.
여기 theta의 함수로서 이 확률들의 그래프가 있어요.
명확히 하자면, 이건 확률 자체의
그래프이지 예를 들어 단일 확률 분포를 묘사하는 그래프가 아니에요.
예를 들어, theta가 1/2이면 보라색으로 그려진 결과 1을 얻을 확률이 1이고
파란색으로 그려진 결과 0을
얻을 확률은 0이에요.
반면에 theta가 1/4이나 3/4이면, 두 결과 각각이 동일하게 가능해요.
그리고 물론 theta의 모든 선택에 대해 확률의 합은 이미 관찰했듯이 1이에요.
그래서 이 절차에서 theta가 정확히 뭔지는 알 수 없지만, theta에 대한 어떤 정보는 줘요.
그리고 theta가 0이거나 theta가 1/2이라는 약속이 있는 상황을 상상하면, 이 절차가
두 가능성 중 정확히 어느 것인지
알려줄 거예요.
그래서 위상 킥백 현상을 사용해서 고유값에 대해 뭔가를 배울 수 있는 간단한 방법이에요.
그러면 고유값에 대해 더 많이
배우려면 어떻게 해야 할까요?
이건 무지가 우리의
안내자가 될 수 있는 상황이에요.
왜냐하면 우리가 할 수 있는 게
별로 많지 않거든요.
고유벡터 psi에 대해 거의 아무것도 모르고, 연산 U에 대해서도 많이 몰라요.
U에 대한 circuit은 있지만, 우리가 아는 한 그건 조사해도 이해할 수 없는 끔찍하고 혼란스러운 것일 수 있어요.
하지만 자연스러운 선택지 하나는 circuit을 여러 번 실행하는 거예요.
특히, 방금 한 것과 정확히 같은 걸 해볼 수 있는데, 단일 제어된 U 연산 대신에
그 연산을 두 번 적용하는 거예요. 몇 번이든 적용할 수 있지만, 뭐가 일어나는지 보려고 두 번부터 시작해 봐요.
실제로 일어나는 건 꽤 간단해요.
제어된 U 연산을 두 번 적용하면 효과적으로 고유값을 제곱하는 거예요.
왜냐하면 한 번이 아니라 두 번
위쪽 qubit의 위상으로 킥백되니까요.
그래서 theta의 함수로서 결과 확률을 생각하면, 본질적으로 주파수를 두 배로 하는 거예요.
theta의 각 가능한 선택에 대해, 결과 확률은 theta를 두 배로 하고 소수 부분을 취해서
0과 1 사이의 숫자를 얻는 것과 같아요.
예를 들어, theta가 1/2이면
고유값은 -1이에요.
그래서 U를 두 번 적용하면 효과적으로 고유값을 제곱하는 거고, 결과는 theta가 0인 것과 같아요.
즉 파란색으로 그려진 결과 0의 확률이 1이고, 보라색으로 그려진 결과 1의 확률이 0이에요.
이건 아주 간단하지만, 이걸 해서 theta에 대한 추가 정보를 실제로 얻을 수 있어요.
예를 들어, theta가 0이거나 theta가 1/4이라는 걸 미리 안다면, 이 circuit이
두 가능성 중 어느 것인지 드러내 줄 거예요.
반면에 theta가 0인 경우와 theta가 1/2인 경우를 더 이상 구별할 수 없어요.
그래서 이 절차가 단일 제어 U gate가 있었을 때보다 엄격하게 더 나은 건 아니지만, 이 circuit도 실행하면
추가 정보를 얻을 수 있어요.
제어된 U 연산을 여러 번 반복해서 얻을 수 있는 추가 정보가
한 번만 수행해서 얻는 정보와 어떻게 조화될 수 있는지 바로 명확하지는 않고, 사실 진행할 수 있는 여러 가지 방법이 있어요.
예를 들어, 반복 위상 추정이라는 기법이 있는데, 우리가 본 것 같은 circuit들을 실행하는 거예요.
약간의 변형과 함께, theta의 근사를 만들어내는 거요.
하지만 저는 좀 더 전통적인 접근 방식을 설명할 건데, 여러 개의 제어 qubit을 사용하는 단일 양자 circuit을 쓰고
각각이 유니터리 연산 U의
다른 횟수의 반복을 제어하는 거예요.
먼저 두 개의 제어 qubit에 대해 이게 어떻게 작동하는지 설명하고, 좀 뒤에 두 개 이상의 제어 qubit으로 일반화할 거예요.
여기 두 개의 제어 qubit을
사용하는 양자 circuit이 있어요.
위쪽 제어 qubit은 단일 U 연산을 제어하고, 위에서 두 번째 qubit은 U의 두 복사본을 제어해요.
그래서 우리가 하는 건 이전에 봤던 두 circuit을 결합하는 건데, 우리가 가진 고유벡터 psi의 단일 복사본을 활용하는 방식으로요.
하지만요.
제어된 U 연산 후의 Hadamard gate가 제거되었고 아직 측정이 없다는 걸 눈치챌 거예요.
우리가 할 건 이 circuit이 어떻게 작동하는지 보고, 그런 다음 우리가 근사하려는 값 theta에 대해
가능한 한 많이 배우기 위해 위쪽 두 qubit에 뭘 해야 하는지 알아내는 거예요.
Hadamard gate가 수행된 후, 화면에 보이는 상태가 돼요.
그리고 이건 다음에 뭐가 일어나는지 보기에 편리한 방식으로 상태를 쓴 거예요.
A 0과 A 1은 비트이고, 위쪽 두 qubit을 2 qubit 레지스터로 생각하면,
위쪽 qubit에 해당하는 A 0을 덜 중요한 비트로, 아래쪽 제어 qubit에 해당하는 A 1을 더 중요한 비트로 생각하는 거예요.
더 중요한 비트로요.
첫 번째 제어된 U 연산이
수행된 후, 이 상태를 얻어요.
위쪽 제어 qubit에 대응하는 고전적 상태가 A 0이니까, 위상 킥백의 결과를
이런 식으로 표현할 수 있어요. 그런 다음 두 번째와 세 번째 제어된 U 연산이
수행된 후, 이 상태를 얻어요.
아이디어는 첫 번째와 같은데, 이번에는 제어 U 연산을 두 번 적용하는 거예요.
그래서 이걸 반영하기 위해
지수에서 A 1에 2를 곱해요.
이제 비트 A 1과 A 0을 함께 이진 표기법을 사용해서 0과 3 사이의 정수로 생각하면 이 표현을 단순화할 수 있어요.
즉, 두 비트 문자열 A 1 A 0을 정수의 이진 인코딩으로 생각하면
얻는 건 2 곱하기
A 1 더하기 A 0이에요.
그리고 ket X라고 쓸 때는 X를 이진 표기법으로 길이 2의 이진 문자열로 쓴 걸 얘기하는 거라고 이해하면 돼요.
이제 이 두 제어 qubit에 집중해서 이 시점에서 theta에 대해 뭘 배울 수 있는지 알아봐요.
나머지 N qubit은 원래 주어진 것과 같은 상태 psi에 여전히 있는데, 이건 이 접근 방식의 정말 멋진 점이에요.
왜냐하면 전에 말했듯이, theta에 대해 더 많은 정보를 얻고 싶으면 그 상태를 다시 사용할 수 있으니까요.
하지만 지금은 이 두 제어 qubit에서 뭘 배울 수 있는지만 생각해 봐요.
어떻게 진행할지 알아내기 위해, theta가 0과 3 사이의 정수 y에 대해 Y/4와 같다고 약속된 걸 상상해 봐요.
0과 3 사이의 정수 y에 대해서요.
일반적으로 theta는 이 네 값 중 하나가 아닐 수 있지만, 이건 고려할 자연스러운 경우예요.
원래 단일 제어 qubit 버전의 절차에서 theta가 0이거나 1/2이라고 약속되면
circuit이 어느 것인지 드러내 줬었어요. 그리고 제어된 U 연산을 두 번 적용한 버전에서는
theta가 0인 경우와 theta가 1/4인 경우를 완벽하게 구별할 수 있었어요.
그래서 새로운 circuit으로 이 네 가지 경우를 구별할 수 있기를 바랄 수 있어요.
본질적으로 우리가 하는 건 약속 문제의 개념을 사용해서 문제를 더 쉽게 만드는 거예요. 어떻게 진행할지 볼 수 있도록요.
그리고 일반적으로 그건 나쁜 생각이 아니에요. 문제가 있는데 어떻게 풀지 모르겠으면, 더 쉽게 만들어 봐요.
더 쉬운 문제를 풀 수 있으면, 얻은 통찰이 더 일반적인 문제를 푸는 데 도움이 될 수 있어요.
그리고 더 쉬운 문제도 풀 수 없으면, 아마 더 일반적인 문제를 풀 준비가 안 된 거예요.
그러니까 풀 수 있을 때까지
계속 더 쉽게 만들어요.
어쨌든, 문제로 돌아가서, Y의 각 가능한 값에 대해 2 qubit 상태를 정의해 봐요.
다시 말해서, phi Y는 theta를 특별히 Y/4로 선택했을 때 화면 위에 보이는 상태와 같아요.
그리고 여기 그 네 상태를
명시적으로 써놓은 거예요.
다시 반복하면, theta가 Y가 0, 1, 2, 또는 3인 경우에 Y/4와 같고 circuit을 실행하면,
이 네 상태 중 하나를 갖게 되는데, Y의 올바른 값에 대응하는 거예요.
그리고 그게 어느 것인지
알아내고 싶은 거예요.
그리고 질문은, 이게 가능한가 하는 거예요.
그 질문의 답은 예인데, 이 네 상태가 직교하기 때문이에요.
어떤 쌍 사이의 내적을
계산해도 0을 얻어요.
그리고 직교하기 때문에 사영 측정으로 완벽하게 구별할 수 있어요.
특히, 여기처럼 각 벡터에 대해 하나의 사영을 정의해서 그런 측정을 표현할 수 있어요.
이건 항상 작동해요. 정규직교 기저가 있을 때마다요. 이 특정 경우에 대해 레슨 3에서 봤던 정의와 대조해 볼 수 있어요.
관심이 있다면요. 그래서 우리의 과제를 달성하는 것이 가능하다는 결론을 내려요.
즉, 화면 위에 보이는 상태에서 Y의 값을 배우는 거예요.
양자 circuit으로 그걸 하고 싶다면, 지금부터 설명할 방식으로 진행할 수 있어요.
먼저 열이 순서대로 나열된 네 벡터인 유니터리 행렬 V를 정의할 수 있어요.
그 행렬은 표준 기저 상태에 대해 화면 아래에 설명된 작용을 할 거예요.
그리고 행렬을 써서
어떻게 생겼는지 볼 수 있어요.
V가 각 표준 기저 상태 kappa Y를 벡터 phi Y로 보내니까, V dagger를 적용하면,
다시 말해서 V 역행렬을 phi Y에 적용하면 대응하는 표준 기저 상태로 다시 변환돼요.
그래서 할 수 있는 건 circuit에서 얻은 어떤 상태든 V dagger를 적용하는 거예요.
그런 다음 표준 기저 측정을 수행하면, 우리가 찾는 숫자 Y를 이진법으로 길이 2의 문자열로 표현된 걸 얻게 돼요.
더 진행하기 전에, 유니터리 행렬 V에 대해 좀 더 얘기해 봐요.
이건 특별한 행렬이고
전에 본 적이 있을 수 있어요.
이건 이산 Fourier 변환이라고 알려진 4차원 벡터에 대한 선형 연산과 관련된 행렬이에요.
더 정확히 말하면, 이산 Fourier 변환은 어떤 양의 정수 차원에 대해서든 정의할 수 있고, 잠시 후에 일반적인 경우를 볼 거예요.
그리고 이건 차원이 4일 때
구체적으로 어떻게 생겼는지예요.
이산 Fourier 변환을
여러 가지 방식으로 생각할 수 있어요.
순수하게 추상적으로 행렬로 표현할 수 있는 벡터에 대한 선형 사상으로 생각할 수 있어요.
벡터가 주어지고 이 선형 사상을 적용한 결과를 계산하려는 계산 문제로도 생각할 수 있어요.
이 선형 사상을 적용하는 거요.
이건 엄청나게 중요한 계산 문제로 밝혀졌고, 그 계산을 수행하기 위한 매우 효율적인 알고리즘이 있어요.
고속 Fourier 변환이라고 알려진 거예요.
사실 이건 예를 들어 신호 처리에서 너무 중요한 문제여서, 고속 Fourier 변환은 많은 사람들에게
지금까지 발견된 가장 중요하고
영향력 있는 알고리즘 중 하나로 여겨져요.
이산 Fourier 변환을 양자 상태 벡터에 적용할 수 있는 유니터리 양자 연산으로도 생각할 수 있어요.
그런 식으로 생각할 때, 양자 Fourier 변환, 줄여서 QFT라고 불러요.
수학적으로 말하면 이산 Fourier 변환과 본질적으로 같은 거지만, 양자 Fourier 변환이라고 부르는 건
양자 상태 벡터에 적용되는 연산이라는 걸 명확히 하기 위해서예요.
그래서 행렬의 이름을 V에서 QFT 4로 바꿔서
우리가 만들어낸 연산이 사실 양자 Fourier 변환이라는 걸 반영해요.
여기 theta가 Y/4와 같다고 약속됐을 때 Y의 값을 배우기 위한 완전한 circuit이 있어요.
Y가 0, 1, 2, 또는 3인 경우에요.
명확히 하자면, 양자 Fourier 변환의 역, 다시 말해서 QFT 4 dagger를 적용하고 있어요.
네 가능한 상태 중 하나를 표준 기저 상태 ket Y로 되돌려서, 측정으로 Y를 복원할 수 있게 하는 거예요.
그래서 위상 추정 문제의 약속 버전에서 생각해서 얻은 circuit이에요. theta가
0, 1/4, 1/2, 또는 3/4라고
약속된 거지만, 이 circuit을
임의의 theta 값에 대해
실행하는 걸 막는 건 없어요.
그렇게 하면, 우리가 얻는
네 가지 가능한 결과의 확률이 이래요.
Y의 네 가능한 값 각각은 자기만의 색깔이 있고, 그래프는 theta의 함수로서 각각의 확률이 뭔지 알려줘요.
예를 들어, theta가 3/4이면
확률 1로 결과 3을 얻고,
다른 세 결과의 확률은 모두 0이에요. 문제의 약속 버전을 생각해서 이미 알고 있듯이요.
theta가 3/4에 가깝지만 정확히 3/4이 아니면, 다른 결과들과 관련된 약간의 비영 확률이 있겠지만,
여전히 높은 확률로
결과 3을 얻을 거예요.
그래서 theta가 Y/4와 같지 않더라도, 측정에서 얻은 결과를 4로 나눈 걸 theta에 대한 추측이나 근사로
생각할 수 있어요.
추측이 틀릴 수 있지만, 그래도 정보를 제공하고 있어요.
그리고 그래프에서 배울 수 있는 한 가지는 가장 좋은 근사가 항상 가장 높은 확률과 연결된다는 거예요.
가장 좋은 근사라고 할 때, Y/4 중에서 theta의 실제 값에 가장 가까운 값을 말하는 거예요.
모듈러 1의 의미에서요. 최악의 경우는 theta가 정확히 Y/4의 두 값 사이의 중간에 있는 거예요.
예를 들어, theta가 3/8이거나
0.375이면, 이 경우 근사값
1/4과 2/4 또는 1/2이
동등하게 좋아요.
그래서 이 특정한 경우에는
하나가 아니라 두 개의 최적 근사가 있어요.
그리고 결과 1과 결과 2를
동일하게 얻을 가능성이 있어요.
다른 두 결과 0과 3은 4로 나눴을 때 theta에 대해 별로 좋지 않은 근사를 주지만, 실제로 약간의 확률로 나타나요.
두 경우 모두 10% 바로
아래인 것 같아요.
그래서 이 절차는 완벽하지 않지만, 정보를 제공해요.
그리고 주목할 만한 건, theta에 상관없이 항상 최적의 근사 또는
동점일 때 두 최적 근사 중 하나를 40% 바로 위인 것 같은 확률로 뽑는 게 보장된다는 거예요.
그리고 theta가 근사에 가까울수록, 해당 Y 값을 볼 확률이 높아져요.
그리고 그건 단일 제어 qubit을
사용하는 것에 비해 꽤 상당한 개선이에요.
이게 사실 두 개의 제어 qubit을
사용할 때의 위상 추정 절차예요.
다음으로 할 건 이 절차를 자연스러운 방식으로 일반화하는 건데, 두 개의 제어 qubit에서 멈추지 않고
원하는 만큼의 제어
qubit을 사용하는 거예요.
보게 될 건 절차를 일반화해서 더 많은 제어 qubit을 추가하면, 점점 더
정확한 theta의 근사를 얻을 수 있다는 거예요. 그리고 그게 일반적인 위상 추정 절차가 돼요.
위상 추정 절차를 두 개의 제어 qubit에서 원하는 만큼으로 일반화하려면, 양자 Fourier 변환이 다른 차원에서
어떻게 정의되는지 이해해야 해요.
그리고 양자 circuit으로 어떻게
구현할 수 있는지도 논의해야 해요.
여기 차원이 임의의 양의 정수 N일 때 양자 Fourier 변환의 정의가 있어요.
여기서 이 연산을 고전적 상태가 0부터 N-1까지인 시스템에 대한 연산으로 생각하고 있어요.
그리고 이 연산을 설명하는 행렬이 디랙 표기법으로 표현되어 있어요.
N이 4일 때 이미 본 것과 연결하기 위해, 표준 기저 상태에 대한 작용으로도 설명할 수 있어요.
N이 1일 때는 이렇게 생겼는데, 별로 흥미로운 경우는 아니에요.
N이 2일 때는 이렇고, 이 경우에 얻는 건 Hadamard 연산이라는 걸 눈치챌 거예요.
N이 3일 때의 양자 Fourier
변환은 이래요.
N이 4일 때는
이미 봤고요.
마지막 예로, N이 8일 때는 이래요.
N이 4인 경우에 있었던 것처럼, 이것들은 각 차원에 대해 이산 Fourier 변환과 연결하는 행렬이에요.
하지만 양자 연산으로 생각하고 싶을 때 양자 Fourier 변환이라고 부르는 거예요.
참고로 이산 Fourier 변환을 행렬로 생각할 때 1/루트N이라는 앞의 인수가 포함되지 않는 경우도 있지만,
유니터리 행렬을 만들기 위해 여기서는 그 인수가 필요해요.
지수에 마이너스 부호가 있는 경우도 있지만, 항상 그런 건 아니에요.
기본적으로 변환의 근본적인 성질을 바꾸지 않는 개인적 선호의 문제예요.
어쨌든, 양자 Fourier 변환을 화면에 써있는 대로 정의할 거예요.
흔히 쓰이는 아주 유용한 축약 표기가 있고, 레슨의 나중에 사용할 거예요.
그건 여기처럼 복소수
omega N을 정의하는 거예요.
구체적으로 e의 2 pi I 나누기 N 거듭제곱인데, 사인과 코사인으로도
여기처럼 쓸 수 있어요. 이 숫자를 N번째 단위근이라고 부르기도 하는데, N 거듭제곱하면 1이 되니까요.
여기 몇 가지 예를 보여주는 그림이 있어요.
Omega 1은 1이고, omega 2는 -1이고, omega 4는 i예요.
일반적으로 omega N을 얻으려면, 단위원을 N명이 나누는 피자처럼 N개의 동일한 크기의 조각으로 자른다고 상상하면 돼요.
그리고 omega N은 첫 번째 조각의 모서리에 있는데, 그 조각의 다른 모서리가 1에 있다고 가정하는 거예요.
그래서 특히 N이 점점 커지면 조각들은 점점 작아지고, omega N은 점점 1에 가까워져요.
이 표기법을 사용하면 양자 Fourier 변환을 좀 더 깔끔하게 표현할 수 있어요.
이 표기법이 레슨 뒤에서 보게 될 것처럼 때때로 것들을 간단하게 유지하는 데 도움이 돼요.
N이 2의 거듭제곱일 때 양자 Fourier 변환의 효율적인 양자 circuit 구현이 있고,
지금 그걸 볼 거예요. 양자 Fourier 변환을 어떤 차원 N에 대해서든 정의하는 경향이 있지만, 위상 추정 절차를 일반화하기 위해서는
N이 2의 거듭제곱인 경우만 필요해요.
이 구현은 화면에 이렇게 묘사된 제어된 위상 gate를 사용할 거예요.
두 개의 제어가 연결된 것처럼 보이고 이 경우 alpha라는 숫자가 있어요.
이 gate의 작용은 여기 보이는 행렬로 설명돼요.
이것들은 말 그대로 제어된 위상 gate예요. 위상 gate를 제어하는 제어 qubit이 있다는 뜻이에요.
레슨 1에서 위상 gate를 봤어요.
하지만 위상 gate의 경우에는 어떤 qubit이 제어이고 어떤 것이 타겟인지가 실제로 중요하지 않아요.
레슨 2에서 Z gate의 특정한 경우에 대해 그걸 봤어요.
이 개념을 갖추었으니, 양자 Fourier 변환을 어떻게 구현할 수 있는지로 넘어갈 수 있어요.
이 구현은 재귀적인 성질을 가지고 있고, 아마 간단한 용어로 설명하는 가장 쉬운 방법은 쉽게 일반화할 수 있는 예를 드는 거예요.
N이 32일 때
어떻게 하는지 보여줄게요.
그러면 5개의 qubit이 있어요.
명확히 하자면, 이 5개 qubit의 표준 기저 상태를 이진 표기법을 사용해서 0과 31 사이의 정수와 연결하고 있어요.
먼저 하는 건 가장 덜 중요한 qubit을 제외한 모든 qubit에 N=16에 대한 양자 Fourier 변환을 수행하는 건데,
가장 덜 중요한 qubit은 위쪽에
있는 거예요. 그게 구성의 재귀적 부분이에요.
이 연산을 구현하려면 같은 패턴을 따르되 qubit이 하나 적은 거예요.
기본 사례에서는 단일 qubit만 있고 양자 Fourier 변환은 그냥 Hadamard gate예요.
위쪽 qubit을 제외한 모든 qubit에 QFT를 적용한 후, 다이어그램에 표시된 위상들을 사용해서 여러 개의 제어된 위상 gate를 적용해요.
그런 다음 위쪽 qubit에 Hadamard gate를 적용하고, 스왑 gate를 사용해서 qubit들을 좀 섞어요.
이 스왑 gate들은 qubit을 순환적으로 치환하는 효과가 있는데, 이게 구성이 작동하는 데 필요해요.
N이 2의 거듭제곱이기만 하면 다른 N에 대해서도 정확히 같은 패턴을 따를 수 있는데, 항상 제어된 위상 gate를
아래쪽 qubit에서 alpha가 pi/2로 시작하고 다이어그램에서 왼쪽으로 이동하면서 2로 나누는 거예요.
후속 위상들을 얻기 위해서요. 이 구성이 작동한다는 건 전혀 자명하지 않아요.
이 영상에서 왜 작동하는지
설명하지는 않을 거예요.
왜 작동하는지의 세부사항에 관심이 있다면, 레슨의 서면 자료에서 찾을 수 있어요.
하지만 여기서 활용되고 있는 건 이산 Fourier 변환의 기본 구조라는 건 말할게요.
사실 고속 Fourier 변환이
작동하게 하는 것과 정확히 같은 구조예요.
이걸 다르게 말하면, 고속 Fourier 변환을 보고 양자 circuit의 관점에서 생각할 수 있어요.
그리고 이게 우리가 얻는 circuit이에요.
그러면 이 구현에 총 몇 개의 gate가 필요할까요?
그걸 알아내기 위해 M개의 qubit이 있을 때 필요한 gate의 수를 SM이라고 해요.
M이 1이면 gate 하나만 필요한데, 이 경우 QFT가 그냥 Hadamard 연산이니까요.
M이 최소 2이면, 이것들이
필요한 gate예요.
먼저 M-1개 qubit에 대한 양자 Fourier 변환을 위해 SM-1개의 gate가 필요해요. 그 숫자가 뭐든 간에요.
또한 M-1개의 제어된 위상 gate, M-1개의 스왑 gate도 필요하고,
추가로 Hadamard gate 하나가 필요해요.
여기 M이 1일 때와 M이 최소 2일 때 두 경우 모두에서 SM의 표현이 있어요.
이건 점화 관계라고 불리는 것의 예이고, 알고리즘 분석에서 아주 흔하게 나타나요.
이 특정한 점화 관계는 아주 간단하고 합산으로 얻을 수 있는 닫힌 형태 표현이 있어요.
정확히 말하면, SM의 값은 처음 M개의 연속 홀수 정수의 합인데, 이건 M 제곱이에요.
전에 만난 적이 있거나 인생의 어느 시점에서 그냥 알아챘을 수도 있어요.
그리고 형식적 증명에 관심이 있다면, M에 대한 귀납법으로 이 공식이 참이라는 걸 증명하는 건 꽤 쉬워요.
그게 다예요. M개 qubit에 대한 양자 Fourier 변환을 M 제곱개의 gate로 구현할 수 있어요.
아주 간단한 추가 비고
몇 가지만 할게요.
먼저 제가 설명한 스왑 gate가
전부 다 필요한 건 아니에요.
제어된 위상 gate가 작용하는 qubit을 적절히 조정하면, 효과적으로 전부 끝으로 밀어내는 게 가능해요.
그렇게 하면 총 M/2개의
스왑 gate만 필요해요(내림).
여전히 이차 비용이지만, 그래도 이런 식으로 gate 수를 줄일 수 있어요.
마지막 비고 하나는 꽤 좋은 근사로 만족한다면 비용을 더 줄일 수 있다는 거예요.
예를 들어, M이 커지면 많은 제어된 위상 gate가 항등 연산에 꽤 가깝고,
아주 가까운 것들을 제거하면 gate를 꽤 많이 절약하면서도 꽤 좋은 근사를 얻을 수 있어요.
양자 Fourier 변환을 아주 얕은 circuit으로 근사하는 것도 가능해요. 즉 깊이가 작은 것으로요, 원한다면 그렇게 할 수 있어요.
이제 다양한 차원에 대한 양자 Fourier 변환이 뭔지, 그리고 차원이 2의 거듭제곱일 때 어떻게 구현할 수 있는지 알았으니,
위상 추정 절차로 돌아가서 임의의 수 M개의 제어 qubit을 사용하는 걸로 어떻게 일반화할 수 있는지 볼 수 있어요.
임의의 M에 대한 양자 circuit으로서 이 절차가 어떻게 생겼는지 보여줄게요.
위쪽에 M개의 제어 qubit이 있고, 모두 0 상태로 초기화된다고 가정해요.
각각에 Hadamard gate를 적용하고, 그런 다음 각각이 유니터리 연산 U의 어떤 거듭제곱을 적용하기 위한 제어 qubit으로 사용돼요.
각 제어 qubit에 대해 U가
적용되는 횟수를 두 배로 해요.
여기 이 다이어그램에서는 제어된 U gate가 그만큼 적용되는 걸 보여주는 대신, 상자 안에 U의 거듭제곱을 표시했어요.
다이어그램을 더 명확하게 하고 화면에 맞도록 공간을 절약하기 위해서예요.
이 절차에 대해 먼저 주목해야 할 건 비용이 매우 커질 수 있다는 거예요.
특히 각 U 연산이 적용되는 횟수를 각 제어 qubit마다 두 배로 하고 있어요.
이걸 하는 방식이 단순히 제어된 U gate를 필요한 만큼 반복하는 거라면,
거대한 circuit을 얻게 돼요.
M에 대해 지수적으로 커질 거예요.
그건 일반적으로 큰 제약이고, 특히 고유값의 정밀한 근사를 얻는 능력을 제한해요.
하지만 곧 다룰 인수분해의 구체적인 경우에는 운이 좋게도 비용의 지수적 폭발을 피할 수 있는 트릭을 쓸 수 있어요.
비용의 지수적 폭발을 피할 수 있어요.
하지만 임의의 유니터리 연산 U에 대해서는 일반적으로 이게 불가능하고 제어 qubit의 수를 늘리는 데
큰 대가를 치르게 돼요.
이 영상에서는 circuit의 상세한 분석을 하지는 않을 거고, 대신 측정 직전의 상태에 대한 꽤 간단한 표현이 있다는 것만 언급할게요.
화면에 보이는 거예요.
그 상태에서 다양한 결과의 확률에 대한 표현을 얻을 수 있고, 이렇게 생겼어요.
이 표현을 갖추면, 이것에 대해 추론할 수 있고, 정말로 이 표현이 계속 진행하는 데 필요한 전부예요.
말했듯이 이 영상에서 세부사항에 들어가지는 않을 거지만, 레슨의 서면 자료에서 찾을 수 있고 실제로 그렇게 복잡하지 않으니까
관심이 있으면 확인해 봐요. 분석을 진행하면 상황이
M=2인 경우와 그렇게 많이 다르지 않다는 걸 알게 되는데, 더 많은 정밀도를 얻는다는 점만 빼고요.
특히 아주 최적의 근사 또는 두 최적 근사 중 하나를 얻을 확률을 먼저 생각해 볼 수 있는데,
이렇게 표현할 수 있어요.
원한다면 절대값에 있는 아래 첨자 1은 무시해도 돼요.
이건 theta=0과 theta=1을 같은 것으로 생각하는 원 위의 근사에 대해 얘기하고 있다는 걸 상기시키기 위해 사용할 수 있는 기호일 뿐이에요.
여기서 핵심은 Y/2의 M 거듭제곱이 theta에 가능한 한 가깝게 만드는 Y의 선택에 대해 생각하고 있다는 거예요.
theta에 가능한 한 가까운 거요.
그리고 다시, M=2인 경우와 마찬가지로, 이 결과 Y를 최소 40%의 확률로 얻는 게 보장돼요.
사실 확률은 최소 4/pi 제곱인데, 40%보다 약간 더 높아요.
급할 때 pi 제곱에 대한
나쁘지 않은 근사가 10이에요.
그리고 이건 사실 꽤 놀라워요. 우리가 얘기하고 있는 건 Y가 정수인 분수 Y/2의 M 거듭제곱으로 theta의 아주 최적의 근사를 얻는 거예요.
그리고 40%보다 큰 확률로
아주 최적의 근사를 얻고 있어요.
더 나쁜 근사에 대해서도
생각해 볼 수 있어요.
구체적으로 Y가 그다지 좋지 않은 경우를 상상해 보고, 더 구체적으로는
theta와 Y/2의 M 거듭제곱 사이에 같은 형태의 더 나은 근사가 있는 경우를 가정해 봐요.
이건 화면에 쓰인 대로
표현할 수 있어요.
그런 경우 이 Y를 얻을 확률은 상대적으로 작을 거예요. 최대 25%요.
실제로는 그보다 낮겠지만, 25%는 꽤 간단한 분석에서 나오는 거고, 충분해요.
예로, 두 개 대신 세 개의 제어 qubit을 사용할 때 얻는 그래프가 여기 있어요.
이번에는 그림이 너무 지저분해지지 않도록 결과 3, 4, 5에 대한 확률만 그렸어요.
theta가 1/2이면 예를 들어, 결과 4를 얻는 게 보장돼요.
그래서 근사를 4/8 또는 1/2로 잡는 거예요. 2의 3 거듭제곱이 8이니까요.
이 경우에는 정확히 맞아요. 그리고 theta가 예를 들어 3/8보다 1/2에 더 가까운 한,
결과 4를 결과 3보다
더 높은 확률로 얻어요.
그리고 다시 40%보다 큰
확률로요.
M이 4일 때의 그래프가 여기 있어요. 곡선이 실제로 거의 동일하게 생겼는데, 2배로 확대된 거예요.
이제 그려진 결과에는 7, 8, 9가 포함되고 근사를 8 대신 16으로 나눈 이 숫자들 중 하나로 잡아요.
그리고 M=5로 증가시킨 그래프를 하나 더 보여줄게요.
다시 2배로 확대할 거예요.
여기 있어요. 다시 곡선이 거의 동일하게 생겼지만, 효과적으로 정밀도를 두 배로 하고 있어요.
그리고 전처럼, 40%보다 큰 확률로 theta의 아주 최적의 근사를 얻었어요.
정말 놀라워요. 하지만 40%가 신뢰도의 척도로 충분하지 않다면,
할 수 있는 건 절차를 적은 횟수로 실행하고, 결과의 최빈값을, 즉 가장 자주 나타나는 걸 취하는 거예요.
그렇게 하면, theta에 대한 아주 좋은 근사를 얻게 될 가능성이 극도로 높아요.
참고로 위상 추정 절차를 실행할 때마다 고유벡터가 변하지 않고 나온다는 걸 기억해요.
그래서 이렇게 절차를 여러 번 실행하는 게 가능해요.
요약하면, theta에 대한 통계를 수집하고 있는 거고, 핵심은 이렇게 해서 theta에 대한 아주 정밀한 근사를
아주 높은 신뢰도로 얻을 수 있고, 이를 위해 절차의 반복이 그렇게 많이 필요하지 않다는 거예요.
그리고 이게 위상 추정
절차가 작동하는 방식이에요.
레슨의 마지막 부분에서는 위상 추정 기법을 정수 인수분해 문제에 적용할 거예요.
영상 시작에서 언급했듯이, 이게 작동하는 방식은 순서 찾기 문제라는 중간 문제를 고려하는 거예요.
위상 추정을 사용해서 순서 찾기 문제를 어떻게 풀 수 있는지 보고, 그런 다음 순서 찾기 문제를 푸는 것이
어떻게 정수를 효율적으로 인수분해하게 해주는지 간략히 얘기할 거예요.
두 번째 부분은 완전히 고전적이고 이 영상에서는 기본 아이디어만 요약할 거예요.
순서 찾기 문제부터
시작해 봐요.
먼저, 편리한 표기법을
준비해 봐요.
모든 양의 정수 N에 대해, ZN을 0부터 N-1까지의 정수로 정의해요.
예를 들어, Z 1은 원소가 하나인데 0이고, Z 2는 원소가 0과 1이고,
Z 3은 원소가 0, 1, 2이고,
이런 식이에요.
그래서 ZN은 집합이에요.
하지만 집합 이상으로도 생각할 수 있어요. ZN에서 덧셈과 곱셈 같은 산술 연산을
모듈러 N으로 정의해서
생각할 수 있어요.
예를 들어, N이 7이라고
가정해 봐요.
3과 5는 Z 7의 원소이고 곱하면 15를 얻는데
7로 나눈 나머지가 1이에요.
때때로 이걸 3 곱하기 5는 모듈러 7에서 1과 합동이라고 쓰는데, 여기 쓰인 것처럼요.
하지만 단순히 3 곱하기 5는 1이라고 쓸 수도 있어요.
물론 3 곱하기 5는 보통
1이 아니라 15예요.
하지만 Z 7에서 작업하고 있다는 게 명확하면, 즉 곱셈이 모듈러 7로 정의되면,
단순히 3 곱하기 5는
1이라고 쓸 수 있어요.
어떤 양의 N에 대해 ZN의 원소 중 일부는 N과 GCD가 1이고
일부는 아닐 거예요. 그리고 N과 GCD가 1인 원소들은 특별해요.
이 원소들만의 집합을 ZN 별표라고 써요.
예를 들어, Z 21 별표는 이래요.
Z 21의 원소 중에서, 물론 21개인데, 12개가 21과 GCD가 1이고 나머지는 아니에요.
특히 3이나 7로 나눠지는 Z 21의 원소는 건너뛰어요.
이 집합이 특별한 이유는 여러 가지가 있는데, 하나는 ZN 별표의 원소가 있을 때
그 숫자의 양의 정수 거듭제곱을 고려하면, 항상 결국 숫자 1에 도달한다는 거예요.
전처럼 모듈러 N의 곱셈을 얘기하는 거예요.
1을 주는 가장 작은 양의 정수 거듭제곱을 그 원소의 위수라고 불러요.
예를 들어, Z 21 별표에서 원소 A=4를 생각해 봐요.
4 곱하기 4는 16인데, 이건 모듈러 21에서 1이 아니에요. 하지만 4를 한 번 더 곱하면
64를 얻고, 64 모듈러
21은 1이에요.
그래서 모듈러 21에서 4의 위수는 3이에요.
이렇게 1에 도달하는 건 ZN 별표의 모든 원소에 대해 항상 일어나요.
참고로, ZN에 있지만
ZN 별표에 없는 원소에 대해서는 절대 안 일어나요.
그래서 N과 GCD가 1인 건 이게 일어나기 위한 필요충분조건이에요.
N=21의 예를 마무리하면, Z 21 별표의 각 원소에 대해 이게 작동하는 가장 작은 양의 정수 거듭제곱이 여기 있어요.
각각 하나씩 확인할 수 있어요.
이제 순서 찾기 문제를 진술할 수 있는데, 이건 단순히 ZN 별표에서 주어진 원소의 위수를 찾는 거예요.
정확히 말하면, 입력은 GCD가 1인 두 양의 정수 A와 N이고,
출력은 A의 R 거듭제곱이 모듈러 N에서 1과 합동인 가장 작은 양의 정수 R이에요.
또는 동등하게 A의 R 거듭제곱이 1인 가장 작은 양의 정수 R이에요.
ZN에서 산술을 한다고 가정하면요.
이건 계산적으로 어려운 문제로 여겨지고, 이걸 풀기 위한 효율적인 고전 알고리즘은 알려져 있지 않아요.
그리고 얘기하겠지만 이 문제는 최소한 정수 인수분해만큼 어려운데, 순서 찾기를 풀 수 있는 알고리즘이 있다면
그 알고리즘을 사용해서 정수 인수분해 문제를 효율적으로 풀 수 있다는 의미에서요.
사실 반대 방향도 성립하는데, 인수분해 알고리즘이 있다면 순서 찾기 문제를 푸는 데 사용할 수 있어요.
그래서 두 문제는 계산적 난이도 면에서 어떤 의미에서 동등해요.
이제 양자 컴퓨터에서 위상 추정을 사용해서 순서 찾기 문제를 어떻게 풀 수 있는지 볼 거예요.
문제들 사이의 연결을 만들기 위해, 고전적 상태 집합이 ZN인 시스템을 상상해 봐요.
ZN 별표의 원소 A에 대해, 여기처럼 연산 MA를 정의할 거예요.
말로 하면 MA가 하는 건 A를 곱하는 거고, 여기서 곱셈은 모듈러 N이에요.
그리고 이 레슨의 나머지에서는 ket 안의 표현은 항상 모듈러 N으로 계산되는 걸로 생각해야 해요.
간단하게 유지하려고 mod N을 계속 쓸 필요가 없도록요.
이건 유니터리 연산인데, A가 ZN 별표에 있기 때문에만 그래요.
A와 N의 GCD가 1이 아니면, 이 연산은 유니터리가 아닐 거예요.
예를 들어 봐요. N이 15이고 A가 2이면, 이건 Z 15 별표에 있고, M 2의 작용은 이래요.
이 예를 잠시 살펴보면, 일어나고 있는 건 ZN의 원소들이 이 작용에 의해 그냥 치환되고 있다는 걸 볼 거예요.
그래서 결정론적이면서 유니터리인데, 행렬로서 MA는 치환 행렬이라는 거예요.
그리고 여기 핵심 아이디어가 있어요. MA의 고유값은 A의 위수와 매우 밀접하게 연결되어 있고
위상 추정을 사용해서 이 고유값들을 충분히 가깝게 근사하면
A의 위수를 결정할 수 있어요. 그러면 MA의 고유벡터와 고유값은 정확히 뭘까요?
전부 다 필요하지는 않고, 일부만 필요해요.
쉬운 예부터 시작해 봐요.
여기 MA의 고유벡터가 있는데, psi 0이라고 이름 붙였고, ket 1, ket a,
ket A 제곱 등등 ket A의 R-1 거듭제곱까지의 합을 R의 제곱근으로 나눈 거예요.
단위 벡터로 만들기 위해서요. 여기서 R은 A의 위수예요.
레슨의 나머지에서 글자 R을 A의 위수로 예약할 거예요.
그래서 R을 보면, 그건 얘기하고 있는 어떤 A든 그 A의 위수예요.
이 고유벡터에 관련된
고유값은 1이에요.
MA를 이 벡터에 적용해서 뭘 얻는지 확인할 수 있어요.
MA는 A를 곱하니까, 각 지수를 1씩 증가시키면 되고 이렇게 돼요.
하지만 A의 위수가 R이니까, A의 R 거듭제곱은 1이에요.
그 치환을 할 수 있어요.
하지만 그건 시작했던 것과 같은 벡터예요. ket들을 섞었을 뿐이지만 합을 취하고 있으니까 아무것도 변하지 않아요.
그래서 MA 곱하기 psi 0은 psi 0과 같아요.
그래서 이건 고유값 1을 가진
MA의 고유벡터예요.
아주 간단한 고유벡터의 예였고, 더 많은 걸 찾기 위해 레슨 앞부분에서 있었던 같은 표기법을 떠올려 봐요.
Omega R은 E의 2 곱하기 pi 곱하기 I 나누기 R 거듭제곱으로 얻는 단위원 위의 복소수예요.
지난번에는 R 대신 N이 있었지만, R을 N 자리에 넣어도 같은 방식으로 작동해요.
이 숫자가 필요한 건 우리가 찾을 MA의 다른 고유벡터들에 나타날 거기 때문이에요.
이 표기법을 떠올렸으니, psi 1이라는 이름의 이 벡터도 MA의 고유벡터라는 걸 관찰할 수 있어요.
psi 0과 비슷한데, 정확히 같은 ket들이 있고 합산해서 R의 제곱근으로 나누고 있어요.
하지만 이번에는 각 ket에 다양한 위상이 곱해져 있어요.
A에 대해 omega R의 -1 거듭제곱, A 제곱에 대해 omega R의 -2 거듭제곱, 이런 식으로 A의 R-1 거듭제곱에 대해 omega R의 -(R-1) 거듭제곱까지요.
그래서 omega R의 거듭제곱은 항상 ket 안에 나타나는 A의 거듭제곱의 -1 배예요.
자세히 설명하지는 않겠지만, 다시 보고 필요할 때 일시정지하고 싶은 분을 위해 화면에 보여주고 있어요.
곱셈을 하고 A의 R 거듭제곱이 1이라는 사실을 사용해서 단순화하면
그리고 omega의 R 거듭제곱이 1이라는 아주 중요한 사실도 사용하면, 다시 MA의 고유벡터를 가지고 있다는 걸 알게 돼요.
이번에는 단순화를 하면서 omega R의 인수를 빼내야 실제로 고유벡터를 가지고 있다는 걸 확인할 수 있고
그 omega R의 벡터가 이 고유벡터에 관련된 고유값을 나타내요.
그래서 이건 MA의 두 번째
고유벡터-고유값 쌍이에요.
정확히 같은 추론을 사용해서 추가 고유벡터를 찾을 수 있고, 사실 omega R을
0과 R-1 사이의 각 J에 대해 omega R의 J 거듭제곱으로 단순히 바꾸면, 항상 고유벡터를 얻고
관련된 고유값은 omega R의 J 거듭제곱이에요.
그래서 이건 이미 본 psi 0과 psi 1뿐만 아니라 R-2개의 다른 고유벡터-고유값 쌍도 포함해요.
전부 기본적으로 같은 방식으로 작동하고, 확인하려면 A의 R 거듭제곱이 1이라는 것과
omega R의 R 거듭제곱이
1이라는 걸 알면 돼요.
예를 들어 ket 0 같은 MA의 다른 고유벡터도 있지만, 유용하지 않을 거고 걱정할 필요 없어요.
psi 0부터 psi R-1까지만 걱정하면 돼요.
이 고유벡터들에 왜 관심을 갖는지, 우리가 찾으려는 위수 R에 대해 뭘 알려줄 수 있는지 이해하기 위해 psi 1에 잠깐 집중해 봐요.
그리고 뭘 알려줄 수 있는지요.
위수 R은 우리가 찾으려는 거예요.
고유벡터 psi 1이 주어졌다고 가정하면, 다음과 같은 방식으로 R을 배울 수 있어요.
먼저, 연산 MA를 구현하는 양자 circuit을 사용해서 이 고유벡터에 위상 추정을 수행해요.
얻는 건 theta의 근사인데, 이 경우 theta는 1/R이에요.
그리고 둘째로, R을 찾고 있고 1/R의 근사를 가지고 있으니, 자연스러운 할 일은 역수를 계산하고
가장 가까운 정수로 반올림하는 거예요. R이 정수여야 하니까 이렇게 반올림해야 해요.
하지만 1/R을 정확히 가진 게 아니라 근사만 가지고 있어요.
하지만 근사가 충분히 좋으면, 반올림했을 때 R을 얻을 거고, 그게 우리가 찾는 거예요.
이제 질문은 역수를 계산하고 반올림해서 R을 올바르게 결정하려면 얼마나 많은 정밀도가 필요한가 하는 거예요.
다시 말해서, 이 모든 게 작동하려면 근사가 얼마나 정확해야 할까요?
꽤 정확한 근사가 필요한 거로 밝혀져요.
예를 들어, 1/R을 1/(R+1)이나 1/(R-1)과 혼동할 여유가 없어요.
그 두 분수 1/(R+1)과 1/(R-1)은 R이 클 때 1/R에 꽤 가까워요.
꽤 정확한 근사가 필요하긴 하지만, 터무니없이 정확한 근사가 필요한 건 아니에요. 근사가
화면에 있는 부등식을 만족하면 반올림했을 때 올바른 답을 줄 거예요.
이 영상에서 그걸 논증하려 하진 않겠지만, 세부사항에 관심이 있다면 레슨의 서면 자료에 나와 있어요.
그 정확도를 목표로 한다면, 위상 추정 절차에서 사용하는 제어 qubit의 수는
N의 길이의 2배 더하기 1이면 충분해요.
이전 레슨에서 있었듯이, N의 길이는 N을 이진법으로 표현하는 데 필요한 비트 수예요.
참고로, 최적의 근사를 최소 40% 확률로 얻는 것에 만족하고 이전에 설명한 대로 신뢰도를 높이려 하지 않으면
실제로 더하기 1은 필요 없어요.
어쨌든, 필요한 제어 qubit의 수가 이진 문자열로 쓴 N의 길이에 선형이라는 거예요.
고유벡터 psi 1이 있으면, 충분한 정확도를 사용해서 위상 추정으로 R을 찾을 수 있다는 걸 봤어요.
불행히도 이 고유벡터를 손에 넣는 건 그렇게 쉽지 않아요.
다른 질문을 해봐요.
psi 1이 아니라 무작위로 선택된 J에 대해 psi J를 가지고 있다고 가정해 봐요.
그래도 R이 뭔지 알아낼 수 있을까요? 아니면 최소한 R에 대해 뭔가를 알아낼 수 있을까요?
답은 예예요. 최소한 평균적으로 R에 대해 뭔가를 알아낼 수 있어요.
할 수 있는 건 방금 본 것과 아주 비슷한 방법으로 J/R을 알아내려고 하는 거예요.
하지만 핵심적인 차이가 있어요.
먼저, 전에 한 것과 정확히 같은 걸 할 건데, 고유벡터 psi J에 위상 추정 절차를 실행하는 거예요.
얻는 건 전에 있었던 1/R이 아니라 J/R의 근사예요.
하지만 이제 작은 문제가 있는데, 역수를 계산하면 R이 아니라 R/J를 줄 거예요.
참고로, J가 뭔지 안다고 가정하는 게 아니에요. 무작위 J에 대해 psi J가 주어진 거고
J가 뭔지 알려주지 않아요. 그러면 뭘 할 수 있을까요?
연분수 알고리즘이라 불리는 잘 알려진 고전 알고리즘이 도움이 될 수 있어요.
이 알고리즘이 할 수 있는 건 우리의 근사 Y/2의 M 거듭제곱을 가져다가, 기약분수 U/V 중에서
U와 V가 모두 N보다 작은 정수인 것 중 우리의 근사에 가장 가까운 걸 알려주는 거예요.
정말 매혹적인 알고리즘이고, 관심이 있다면 꼭 확인해 봐야 해요.
사실 유클리드의 GCD 계산 알고리즘과 매우 밀접하게 연결되어 있어요.
하지만 이 영상에서 더 이상
얘기하지는 않을 거예요.
여기서 핵심은 분자와 분모가 너무 크지 않은 어떤 분수에 대한 좋은 근사가 있으면,
알고리즘이 그 분수를 복원할 수 있다는 거고, 그게 여기서 하고 있는 거예요.
이제 전과 정확히 같은 질문이 남아요. 얼마나 많은 정밀도가 필요할까요?
전에 있었던 것과 정확히 같은 경계가 이 경우에도 작동해요.
그래서 M을 전과 정확히 같은 방식으로 선택하면 여기서도 작동해요.
이게 반드시 R을 알려주지는
않을 수 있어요.
충분한 정밀도를 사용하면 배우게 되는 건 J/R인데, 이건 기약분수일 거예요.
그래서 무작위 J 선택이 R과 공통 인수를 가질 수 있다는 점에서 운이 나쁠 수 있고,
그건 우리에게 숨겨질 거예요. 최악의 경우 예를 들어 J=0을 얻을 수 있고 그러면 아무것도 배우지 못해요.
하지만 그건 말 그대로 아무것도
배우지 못하는 유일한 경우예요.
일반적으로 최소한 R의 비자명한 인수를 얻게 되고, 무작위 표본을 뽑아서
다른 J 선택에 대해 psi J를 얻을 수 있으면, 관찰하는 모든 분모의 최소공배수를 계산해서 사실 높은 확률로 R을 복원할 수 있어요.
그리고 이건 실제로 그렇게 많은 표본을 필요로 하지 않아요.
결론은 일부 J 선택이 R의 인수를 숨길 수 있지만, 무작위 J 선택은
R의 인수를 오래 숨기지
못할 거라는 거예요.
그게 아이디어예요. 구현을 고려하고 특히 비용이 얼마나 드는지 알아내는 게 남아 있어요.
아이디어의 핵심은 ZN 별표에서 주어진 원소 A의 위수를 계산하기 위해 연산 MA에 위상 추정 절차를 적용하는 거예요.
연산 MA에요.
대문자 N의 길이의 함수로서 이 비용이 얼마인지 알아봐요. 소문자 n으로 표시할게요.
여기 위상 추정을 위한 circuit이 있어요. ZN의 원소를 이진법으로 인코딩하기 위해 circuit 아래쪽에 소문자 n개의 qubit이 필요해요.
그래서 위쪽에 N개의 제어 qubit이 있고 아래쪽에 소문자 n개의 qubit이 있는데,
이건 좋은 게 레슨 앞부분에서 사용한 이름과 일치하니까요.
전체 circuit에 필요한 gate 수를 세기 위해 먼저 제어된 유니터리 연산의 비용에 집중해 봐요.
이전 레슨, 레슨 6의 기법을 사용하면, 모듈러 N 산술을 위한 효율적인 고전 알고리즘을 사용해서 MA를 big O(n 제곱)개의 gate로 구현할 수 있어요.
모듈러 N 산술을 위한 효율적인 고전 알고리즘을 사용해서요.
이 영상에서 세부사항은 생략하겠지만, 얘기한 다른 여러 것들처럼 레슨의 서면 자료에서 더 읽어볼 수 있어요.
하지만 MA만 구현하는 것으로는
충분하지 않아요.
MA 제곱, MA의 4 거듭제곱, 8 거듭제곱 등등도 구현해야 하고
M에서 지수적인 거듭제곱까지 가야 해요.
충분한 정밀도를 얻으려면 M을 소문자 n에 선형으로 잡아야 한다는 걸 알고 있어요.
이건 큰 우려이고,
앞서 제기했었어요.
MA를 단순히 반복해서 MA의 거듭제곱을 구현하면 곤란해질 거예요. MA의 이 모든 반복이 지수적 비용을 발생시키니까요.
다행히 이 비용 폭발을 피할 수 있는 트릭을 쓸 수 있어요.
할 수 있는 건 이래요. 필요한 각 거듭제곱 K에 대해서요.
먼저, 모듈러 N에서
A의 K 거듭제곱을 계산해요.
이건 레슨 6에서 언급했던 모듈러 거듭제곱 문제예요.
효율적으로 풀 수 있어요. 그리고 이건 고전 컴퓨터로 할 수 있는 거예요.
이 계산은 양자 circuit으로
수행될 필요가 전혀 없어요.
결과를 B라고 해요.
그래서 B는 ZN 별표의 원소예요.
둘째로, MA의 K 거듭제곱 대신에 그냥 MB에 대한 circuit을 사용해요.
그게 다예요. B는 그냥 ZN 별표의 원소니까, MB를 구현하는 비용은 big O(n 제곱)이에요.
핵심적으로 우리가 하고 있는 건 양자 circuit을 거듭제곱하는 게 아니라 ZN에서 거듭제곱하는 거예요.
하지만 실제로 얻는 연산은 어느 쪽이든 같아요. 그냥 A를 K번 곱하는 거예요.
이건 사실 기적 같아요. 이것 없이는 순서 찾기 문제를 풀거나 양자 컴퓨터로 정수를 효율적으로 인수분해할 수 없었을 거예요.
이것 없이는요.
거듭제곱을 포함해서 각 제어된 유니터리 연산이
big O(n 제곱) 비용으로 구현될 수 있다는 걸 알았으니, 필요한 총 gate 수를 셀 수 있어요.
N개의 Hadamard gate가 있고, M이 big O(n)이니까 비용은 big O(n)이에요.
M개의 제어된 유니터리 연산이 있고 각각 big O(n 제곱) 비용이에요.
그래서 여기 총 비용은
big O(n 세제곱)이에요.
그리고 마지막으로, 양자 Fourier 변환의 비용은 big O(n 제곱)이에요.
그래서 총 비용은 big O(n 세제곱)이에요.
특히, 모듈러 거듭제곱 트릭을 써도 제어된 유니터리 연산의 비용이 지배적이에요.
하지만 그래도 비용은
소문자 n에 대해 다항적이에요.
모듈러 거듭제곱 계산이나 연분수 알고리즘 실행 같은 고전적 계산도 필요하지만,
그 계산들도 다항 비용이에요. 사실 big O(n 세제곱) 연산으로 할 수 있어요.
남은 문제가 하나만 있는데, 이 고유벡터들 중 하나를 손에 넣어야 한다는 거예요.
어떻게 할 수 있을까요?
해결책은 사실 아주 간단해요. circuit을 고유벡터에 대해 실행하지 않아요.
그냥 상태 1에 대해 실행해요. 숫자 1의 이진 인코딩을 말하는 건데, ZN의 원소로 생각하는 거예요.
다이어그램에서 그 치환을 해봐요.
이게 작동하는 이유는 바로 여기 이 방정식 때문이에요.
상태 ket 1은 사실 우리가 얘기해 온 R개의 고유벡터의 균일한 중첩이에요.
바로 명백하지는 않지만, 합을 계산해 보면 ket 1을 얻어야 해요.
이 상태에 대해 circuit을 실행하면, 얻는 출력은 J를 무작위로 선택하고
고유벡터 psi J에 대해
절차를 실행한 것과 정확히 같아요.
역시 명백하지는 않지만, 분석하면 사실이라는 게 드러나요.
그리고 마지막으로, 그게 다예요. 순서 찾기를 위한 효율적인 양자 알고리즘을 갖게 됐어요.
레슨의 아주 짧은 부분이 하나 남아 있는데, 정수 인수분해와 순서 찾기의 관계에 관한 거예요.
순서 찾기 문제를 효율적으로 풀 수 있으면, 정수도 효율적으로 인수분해할 수 있다고 언급했어요.
이게 어떻게 작동하는지 핵심 아이디어를 아주 간략하게 알려줄게요.
완전히 고전적이에요. 이 부분은 사실 양자 컴퓨팅과 아무 상관이 없어요.
주어진 양의 정수 N의
비자명한 인수를 찾는 방법이 여기 있어요.
참고로, 이 방법은 N이 홀수이고 소수의 거듭제곱이 아닐 때만 작동해요.
N이 짝수이거나 소수 거듭제곱인 두 경우는 따로 처리할 수 있어요.
그 두 경우를 감지하고 처리하기 위한 효율적인 고전적 방법이 있어요.
이 방법은 확률적이에요. 실패할 수 있지만, 실패 확률은 최대 반이고,
오류 확률을 지수적으로 빠르게 줄이기 위해 독립적으로 여러 번 실행하면 돼요.
먼저, 2와 N-1 사이에서
균일하게 무작위로 A를 선택해요.
그런 다음 A와 N의 GCD를 계산해요.
GCD가 1보다 크면, 엄청 운이 좋은 거예요.
GCD가 N의 인수가 될 거고 그걸 출력하고 멈추면 돼요.
아니면 알고리즘은 계속 진행하고 이제 A가 ZN 별표에 있다는 걸 알게 돼요.
이제 A의 위수를 계산하는데, 여기서 양자 컴퓨터가 필요해요.
아니면 위수를 계산하는 다른 방법이 있을 수도 있어요. 알고리즘은 어디서 오는지 신경 안 쓰지만, 이걸 효율적으로 하는 유일한 방법은
양자 컴퓨터를 사용하는 거예요.
위수 R이 짝수이면, A의 R/2 거듭제곱 빼기 1과 N의 GCD를 계산해요.
그 GCD가 1보다 크면, 다시 N의 인수를 가진 거니까 출력하고 멈춰요.
아니면 알고리즘이 실패한 거예요. 그 경우에는 처음으로 돌아가서 다른 A를 선택하고
다음번에 더 나은 결과를
바라면 돼요.
그게 다예요. 참고로, N의 인수를 찾으면 그 인수와
그 인수로 나눈 것에 대해 N의 소인수분해를 가질 때까지 재귀할 수 있어요.
그러면 이게 왜 작동할까요?
핵심 포인트가 두 가지 있어요. 첫째, A의 R 거듭제곱이 모듈러 N에서 1과 합동이니까,
N은 A의 R 거듭제곱 빼기 1을 나눠요.
이 두 진술은 사실 동치예요. 이건 정수론 책에서 찾을 수 있는 mod N의 정의예요.
둘째, R이 짝수이면, 여기 있는
이 방정식이 성립해요.
이건 잘 알려진 제곱의 차 공식이에요.
사실 이 방정식은 모든 R에 대해 성립하지만, 4단계에서 R/2가 정수여야 해요.
두 사실을 합치면, N의 모든 소인수가 괄호 안의 두 표현 중 하나를 나눠야 한다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
그게 N이 곱을 나눌 수 있는
유일한 방법이니까요.
N의 모든 소인수가 첫 번째 괄호 표현을 나누고 두 번째는 나누지 않을 수 있지만, 우리의 무작위 A에 대해
그건 별로 가능성이 높지 않아요. 4단계에서 GCD를 계산하면 N의 소인수 중 일부의 곱을 얻을 가능성이 높지만
전부는 아닌 거예요.
이걸 꼼꼼히 분석하려면 정수론이 필요하지만, 꽤 기본적인 정수론이에요.
정수론이 흥미롭고 더 배우고 싶다면, 이 분석을 직접 해보세요.
이런 걸 직접 해보는 건 더 배우기 위한 훌륭한 방법이지만, 그건 여러분에게 맡길게요.
레슨은 여기서 끝이에요. 이번 레슨에서 위상 추정 문제, 양자 컴퓨터에서 이걸 효율적으로 푸는 방법,
그리고 그 풀이를 적용해서 정수 인수분해를 위한 다항 비용 양자 알고리즘을 얻는 방법을 다뤘어요.
다음 레슨에서 함께하길 바라요. 다음은 Grover의 양자 탐색 알고리즘에 대한 거예요.
그때까지 안녕히.